queen side which she could have had
white white could still try to win this
position because uh the old uh saying is
you you've got to play against two
weaknesses black's kind of got a
weakness with the harry porn i would say
um so you but you need another weakness
to win this game let's go back to the
players we're going to see a draw any
moment look at this pawn structure as
well strange this is the most locked
pawn structure you will ever see
simply nothing to do neither side can
push forward without losing a pawn
and
look how kind of irrelevant the rooks
are here no open lines for them and i'm
going to see the kings do a bit of
dancing that's it and ariane's king has
wandered all the way is it going to come
back again are they going to repeat
moves actually by just moving the kings
backwards and forwards magnus is
repeating no doubt about that and we
have a draw between the two norwegians
in a very strange porn situation on this
board i want to take a picture of that
that's very cool we don't see that often
but a draw four these two so we're gonna
jump into another game